if you want to check out any of the
products that I've talked about in
today's video you can click the view
products label beneath this video and
you can shop them directly from here
this is the Brava home oven and this is
an infrared oven you have this
incredible library of recipes that you
can basically make anything that you can
even think of one of my favorite
features though is you can connect it to
your phone and there's a camera inside
of the oven so you could actually watch
your food cook I have several different
sizes of these Dyson purifiers and the
one that I have here is the formaldehyde
one this is using Dyson's most advanced
filtration system so it combines a
precise solid state formaldehyde sensor
with a unique filter that continuously
destroys formaldehyde this is nanoleaf
these have thread technology so you
don't need some separate kind of Hub it
was super easy all I had to do was scan
the QR code I installed the light and it
automatically connected to my home I'm
so excited about this I buy new lights
my new pink wall spoiler alert for
future video